by joining us now with more reaction to
our opening monologue the author of the
best-selling book trumped up how
criminalization of political differences
in dangers democracy Professor Alan
Dershowitz and former US Attorney for
the District of Columbia
Jodi Jennifer two of the smartest
lawyers in the country you know last
night I got such incredible reaction to
your comments collusions not a crime but
it could but we go from collusion to
obstruction to them bank records he's
not a target but the media is like well
he's not a target but he's still in
jeopardy it's like there's no winning
here I have to tell you if after a year
of very thorough investigation and going
after all the low-hanging fruit and
getting people not only to sing but some
of them even perhaps to compose if they
couldn't have shifted him from a subject
to a target there's nothing there what
are they hoping us of course they're
hoping but I think they understand that
now they're going after very very weak
issues collusion I challenged Muller to
tell me what statute is violated by
collusion there's a memo now by
Rosenstein authorizing him to
investigate collusion with the Russians
by manna for but you can't investigate
sins you can only investigate federal
crimes and there is no such federal
crimes collusion how do they not know
that they know it but they hope that by
investigating collusion they'll get
somebody to obstruct justice to commit
perjury to commit one of these other
peripheral crimes as they always say
it's in the cover-up but it's not the
cover-up it's that prosecutors induce
cover-ups which is why innocent people
shouldn't be testifying unless they
absolutely have to because you can be
indicted for perjury even if you tell
the truth if you say something that
somebody else says a debts a spectacular
statement you can be you can be indicted
for perjury even if you tell the truth
that's right because if somebody
contradicts you and the prosecutor
believes the person contradicting you
you're indicted for perjury even though
you told the truth I'm going to get back
to that question and in just a second
let me go to Jodi Jennifer Joe rod
Rosenstein issues this letter to Muller
mm-hmm allowing him to go after Paul
Manafort of the way he did a week after
they did
the rate now why do I think the order of
that legally needs to be reversed well
let's say this first of all about rosin
rod Rosen Stein his conduct from the
beginning of this has been a disgrace
legally and every other way he is an
embarrassment to the administration it
is truly too bad that he cannot be fired
but let's let's be very clear about this
the president has never been a target
the fact that he has been recently
notified that he is a subject means
absolutely nothing he is not even a
subject he is a witness a subject is a
person whose conduct is within the scope
of the grand jury's investigation what
the hell does that mean it means they
don't have anything on him there have
been 19 criminal cases not one piece of
evidence against the President of the
United States and now we are told that
Muller wants to wants to interview the
President of the United States who knows
nothing who has been a witness to
nothing who is not a target of the
investigation what we are seeing now is
conduct by two public officials Robert
Muller and rod Rosenstein that is
unethical unprofessional and
embarrassment to the United States
government and is undermining equal
enforcement of the law there's no
because of what they are doing to a
president of the United States Rod
Rosenstein single-handedly has taken
away from the sitting president of the
United States 16 months of his
presidency by his incompetent and
fearful conduct you know why rob rodeen
Stein appointed Muller because he didn't
want to make the tough decisions that
you'd have to make if you were
supervising a case being run by a United
States Attorney like Huber rod
Rosenstein is a coward he's a disgrace
to the Department of Justice it's a
shame and you can't the president cannot
fire well you know it's an apolitical
consequence they can't fire him but it's
amazing that he hasn't been recused
after all he is the main witness on
whether or not collusion or whether and
I'm sorry whether or not obstruction of
justice occurred with the firing of
Comey and the members are gonna have
absolute right to fire anybody well he
does but you know politically there's a
difference between having the right to
do it and it being right
to do it she want to comment on one
thing that Joe said he's absolutely
right that they have deprived the
president of the opportunity to govern
but the Republicans did the same thing
to Clinton when they impeached him they
knew they were never gonna get him he
still 67 years into his presidency well
but still they they made a mistake and I
think they paid a heavy consequence for
it I think the Democrats would pay a
heavy cost if they made the same mistake
trying to impeach without being able to
remove I want to ask my way by the way I
want to say something about this notion
that Muller wants to question the
president what does he want to question
him about right this is my question
though she doesn't question him about
the firing of Comey that is an article
to constitutional authority I think the
president has to fire Comey
he had every right to fire Flynn I
suppose they say what were you thinking
when you fired Comey what were you
thinking when your question is that
these are the kind of stupid questions
let me clear off this question of both a
perjury trap plane and sangria which is
neutral sex
this is a dilute ly outrageous end right
now here's the question I have because
I'm sure robert muller does want to
question the president professor yeah i
would advise him not to I'm not I don't
have your your your experience well me
it's a trend here's the written
questions the problem the question Joe
one second hang on professors the
problem the the special counsel has the
power to put him in front of a grand
jury without a lawyer so he has some
leverage what I would suggest and the
president
she might consider this is if he's asked
the question why did you fire Comey his
answer is you're not allowed to ask me
or question any article to decision I
make just like you can't question
senators to their vote you can't
question justices for the vote if I
acted within the authority of article
two I cannot be compelled or asked why I
did something would you advise this
president to say no to any interview
well I'm not advising the press garol
state would you advise the president I
would I would suggest that it would be
best if the President refused to answer
certain questions that intrude
his article to powers last last work Joe
same question the president should not
agree to an interview in my opinion and
I'm not giving him legal advice I'm
talking on this show
the president should act the most and
Sir written questions in a very limited
area and he should never ever be
interviewed this is an abomination if it
lives long fight over executive
privilege that that that battle should
be waged it in my opinion the president
should not sit down for an interview he
can answer written questions in a very
limited area maybe ten twelve question
what if he subpoenaed what if he
subpoenaed in front of the group well I
think what you do at that point is you
have to arm you have to argue Article
two and if Bob Muller wants to take the
President of the United States who is
not involved in any of the 19 charges
that he has brought thus far into a
court over testimony I think that that
is would be one of the most disgraceful
periods in American history absolutely
outrageous you got you guys are amazing
I I I want you guys on every night this
is this is really important commentary
thank you Bob and it's rare that Joe and
I agree about it I know that today we
agree perfection